[Music]
hey guys welcome to Harry Potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing a question that I'm short at
the forefront of many Harry Potter fans
mind who is more powerful Voldemort or
Dumbledore Voldemort and Dumbledore the
yin and yang of Wizards each extremely
powerful and a strong representative of
the classic relationship between good
and evil each one acting as a symbol for
the invariable struggle between light
and darkness
we know how Harry Potter ends and we
know that Voldemort is unsuccessful in
securing shroud of Darkness over the
world but that doesn't mean that he
wasn't the most powerful wizard of all
time and the fact that light prevailed
doesn't mean that Dumbledore was the
most powerful wizard we've got to look
deeper many assume that because
Voldemort ultimately lost and because
Dumbledore is good that Dumbledore is
the more powerful figure however this is
not a sound argument whether you are
good or evil has nothing to do with your
inherent power from an extremely young
age Tom Riddle showcased intensely
powerful innate magical abilities he was
a magical prodigy if you will as he grew
older and he began to harness his
abilities riddle became unimaginably
powerful performing feats of magic that
people thought previously impossible
and he knew it too proclaiming to Harry
in the air of southern that he was the
greatest sorcerer in the world to which
Harry retorts Dumbledore is the greatest
sorcerer in the world reminding middle
of Dumbledore and subsequently angering
him in my view this anger showed
insecurity in riddle Harry statement
reminding him of Dementors power forced
him to consider his own magical ability
in relation to Dumbledore's I think that
he a knows that Dumbledore is more
powerful and became angry because he
resents it or be is just completely
unsure of whether or not Dumbledore is
more powerful and fears it as a
possibility
while Voldemort showed extreme magical
prowess from a young age he was not
alone Dumbledore's magical abilities can
distantly turned heads at Hogwarts as
well particularly his skills surrounding
charms and Transfiguration he also did
exceptionally well on his newts and
christelle de Marchbanks a professor
working for the wizarding examinations
authority remarks that Albus was able to
do things with a wand that she had never
seen before
not only that but Dumbledore befriended
Grindelwald as a very young age and I
believe that this had a profound impact
on Dumbledore skill the two spent lots
of time together practicing magic and
Grindelwald was known to have come from
a powerful magical bloodline his
great-aunt Matilda Bagshot publishing a
history of magic a magic book used to
teach students at Hogwarts
Dumbledore who always out shown everyone
magically was challenged by another for
the first time and I believe that this
resulted in even greater power for the
both of them so we've established that
both of them were powerful right from
the start showing an innate capability
for magic and an affinity for learning
new skills and abilities so where's this
leave us how can we definitively
determine who was more powerful
Dumbledore was known for being all too
modest and in the first book there was a
moment where I believe it is partially
suggested that Dumbledore is the more
powerful sorcerer or if not more
powerful possessing the inherent
capability to be more powerful if he so
desired
McGonigle says to Dumbledore but you're
different everyone knows you're the only
one who you know who oh all right
Voldemort was frightened of you
flattered me said Dumbledore calmly
Voldemort had powers I will never have
to which McGonagall replies only because
you're too well noble to use them to me
this hints that perhaps Dumbledore has a
higher overall threshold for power than
Voldemort but there he is perhaps not
willing to make the same sacrifices and
for that reason never achieving quite
the same level of power Voldemort's
level of power was achieved by any means
possible with no exceptions his pursuit
of power was filled with ignorance
showing disregard for the consequences
of the pursuit of dark magic he dealt
further into the darkness than anyone
before him and became more powerful
because of it but perhaps at too great a
cost he lost himself with that being
said even though he plunged himself into
magic as much as possible Voldemort at
no point in the books or films appears
to exhibit magical ability that far
exceeds or outweighs Dumbledore when
they fight in the Ministry atrium they
actually seem evenly matched for the
most part though I would argue that
Dumbledore slightly edges him out
however there are a few things to
consider here number 1 Dumbledore was in
possession of the Elder Wand
and number 2 Dumbledore was not really
trying to defeat him simply Ward him off
it's hard to say how much the elder one
helped Dumbledore but given how close
they still were to me it suggests that
at that time Voldemort was perhaps
slightly more powerful edging out
Dumbledore with the power that came from
his plunge into darkness this makes me
think what would Dumbledore have been
like if he were evil
what insane level of power could he have
achieved clearly embracing the darkness
opens up a whole of the spectrum of
magic but in the case of Dumbledore it
seems like he would never have even
needed it showing such prowess while
remaining entirely himself and with no
sacrifice to his soul while Voldemort
relied on darkness
Dumbledore's power stemmed from trust
love and a belief in the greater good
something that I will address quickly is
that some field that Grindelwald is a
factor in this equation and that he is
in the same league as Voldemort and
Dumbledore Grindelwald isn't really the
topic of this video so I'm not going to
dive into it too much but I will say
that I disagree with him being on their
level Green noir was powerful but the
sole fact that Dumbledore was able to
defeat him even though he was wielding
the Elder Wand and embracing dark magic
sort of takes him out of the equation
for me to summarise I think that during
the timeline of the books in the movies
Voldemort and Dumbledore are almost on
par with each other with Voldemort
slightly edging him out
Voldemort's advantage is that he
effectively harnesses the darkside of
magic and done with those advantages are
number one that he is in possession of
the other one and number two that he is
able to trust in the greater good
however I think that while both of them
show immense innate magical ability
Dumbledore possesses more of it in his
lifetime he achieves nearly the same
level of power that Voldemort achieves
at no cost to his well-being or soul he
achieves his power without exploring or
leveraging an entire side of the magical
spectrum Voldemort is actively more
powerful but Dumbledore has only
scratched the surface of his power he
possesses the ability to be far more
powerful was just unwilling to make the
same sacrifices that Voldemort made this
is why I think that Voldemort always
feared Dumbledore the unknown threshold
of Dumbledore's power this is why the
subject of Dumbledore's power was always
a bitter pill for Voldemort to swallow
I hope that you guys enjoyed the video
what do you think do you agree do you
disagree who do you believe is it more
powerful
let me know down in the comment section
below until next time you're a wizard
Harry
you